In this video we take a look at setting
up a custom loss function for training.
In the default loss functions all
samples such as these code snippets
are treated the same irrespective of their
content, but there are scenarios where you it
could make sense to weight the samples
differently. If for example one sample
contains a lot of tokens that or of interest to
us or it has a favourable diversity of tokens.
We can also think of other heuristics we can
implement with pattern matching or other rules.
For each sample we get a loss value during
training and we can combine that loss with
a weight. Then we can for example create a
weighted sum to get the final loss for a batch.
Let’s have a look at a specific example: we
want to setup a language model that helps us
autocomplete complete common data science code.
For that task we would like to weight samples
stronger where tokens related to the data science
stack, such as pd or np, occur more frequently.
Here you see a loss function that does exactly
that for causal language modeling. It takes the
models it takes the model’s inputs and predicted
logits as well as the key tokens as input. First
the inputs and logits are aligned, then the loss
per sample is calculate followed by the weights.
Finally the loss and weights
are combined and returned.
This is a pretty big function so let’s take
a closer look at the loss and weight blocks.
During the calculation of the standard loss the
logits and labels are flattened over the batch.
With the view we unflatten the tensor
to get a matrix with a row for each
sample in the batch and a column for each
position in the sequence of the samples.
We don’t need the loss per position so we average
the loss over all positions for each sample.
For the weights we use boolean logic to get
a tensor with 1s where a keyword occurred
and 0s where not. This tensor has an additional
dimension as the loss tensor we just saw because
we get the information for each keyword in a
separate matrix. Only want to know how many
times keywords occurred per sample so we can sum
over all keywords and all positions per sample.
Now we are almost there, we only need to combine
the loss with the weight per sample. We do this
with element wise multiplication and then
average over all samples in the batch.
In the end we have exactly one
loss value for the whole batch.
And this is the whole necessary logic
to create a custom weighted loss.
Let’s see how we can make use of that custom loss
with Accelerate and the Trainer In Accelerate we
just pass the input_ids to the models to get the
logits and can then call the custom loss function.
After that we continue with the normal
training loop by for example calling backward.
For the Trainer we can overwrite the compute
loss function of the standard trainer. We
just need to make sure that that we return the
loss and the model outputs in the same format.
With that you can integrate your own awesome loss
function with both the trainer and accelerates.